Steven Shea, Filmmaker: If you're
going out to be a grip or an electric,
go work on The Avengers. While they're hiring
a hundred grips and they're hiring two writers.
Film Courage: We had this comment come in the
other day under one of our videos and it's
the thing that no older quote successful
artist understands is that just make it is
not an option when you are a young artist and
have to work in a cafe part-time to survive.
Steven: I feel like there's a lot of people
that give that advice “just go out and make it,
go out and make your thing” and it's definitely
a blessing and a curse. If you go out with your
friends and you make something that is absolutely
atrocious that everyone thinks is funny but then
you show it to someone else and they're kind
of like well you can't show anybody this is
terrible it'll make you look bad you don't want
to do that at the especially the beginning and I
had that situation out with one of our projects
where we did a whole proof of concept and spent
a lot of money and did a lot of time and energy
and work and we did it the best we possibly could
and then we showed it to some bigger people and
they were like well this is bad you can't show
anyone this and it was like oh okay and we had to
pull it you know we had to recut it and tighten
it up and not show it to anyone because they
were like this is detrimental to your career
if you're looking to build a career off
of this this isn't going to help you out
and so at some point you have to understand that
too that if if you do run into that situation
then you make a decision but I mean everything
comes down to marketing you can release a movie
and not do any marketing and the movie exists
but no one's seen it so they're probably not
gonna have watched it anyway when you have it on
your resume or you have it on your IMDB it's like
oh yeah you made all these movies I haven't seen
them but that's cool that you made those movies
because if you're not marketing and getting the
word out that no one's gonna watch it anyway
especially so I think that it's it changes
too nowadays it's gotten so much cheaper
and easier to make higher quality content I mean
you look at you know a professional camera package
you can probably get for under 10 grand now
whereas 20 years ago it would have been 200 grand
so you can make good quality stuff nowadays
easier but everything has to be good quality
to make this ultimate movie that's really going
to impress people to launch you to that next level
and I think a lot of people don't have the ability
to do that I mean I have friends in town that they
were like oh you have cameras and lights and
sound and I'm like oh yeah I've got everything
they're like oh wow because I always wanted to
make this video but I have no way of doing it
and it's like well you find somebody else that
does have it and hopefully at some point this is
one of the good benefits of film schools I'm not a
firm believer in film schools but you want to find
your your crew you want to find your tribe and
if there's a way to build that a film school is
the best way to do that the school itself is going
to do whatever but it's finding those other people
that are like-minded that maybe have equipment
and you try to build that up and especially now
with social media finding other people nearby you
is a lot easier and seeing who is the camera who
has lights who's an actor and then trying
to put something together that hopefully
isn't horrible or you start doing horrible things
and say okay well this is a good this was fun but
now let's do something better because every time
you do it it's only going to get better and better
and better hopefully and if it's not then maybe
you should look into a different career because
might not be for you well and if you didn't
go to a film school you can still find your
quote try but I think it would take a little bit
longer but I mean you can you can meet fantastic
people on Craigslist you can meet also some scary
people on Craigslist but you know or you could
find people on Mandy or whatever and it might just
take longer to piece together reliable people that
you have the same personality type
you can work well together you know
and I think it's definitely a stigma in
the industry which I i don't disagree with
nowadays where it's kind of like hey looking for
a crew to make this movie paying you in in lunch
and IMDB credit and it's kind of like you know if
I was 20 i'd have been like that's awesome I want
to totally jump on that guy's team and do this but
at 40 I'm kind of like all right well what are you
doing kid like you know you need to pay those
people because they have rent and families and
so it's definitely become a problem to where our
industry also doesn't really put the value in
what exactly we're bringing to the table because
I think a lot so many people don't understand it
I always compare it to when I go get my
car fixed I have no idea how to fix a car
I have nowhere I don't know where anything
I barely can put the gasoline and let alone
know what the engine does so it's like those guys
are like well I work for 80 an hour it's like okay
here's your 80 an hour go fix my car because
I have no idea what you're doing but then when
someone comes to a filmmaker or a camera operator
or someone that's like oh yeah I work for 80
an hour and they're like what are you talking
about all you do is press a button and like
there's a strange mentality around the industry
about that that devalues what exactly we do and
you watch these big movies there's
a thousand people's names in the
credits it's like every single one of these
people had to do something to pull off this
thing you just watched for two hours in your
your living room so that stigma is unfortunate
because it the devaluing everything and telling
film school kids will go out and work for free
for the first 10 years and it's like well how do
you do that like that's you kind of need to pay
your bills and survive but then you have to get
better and it's always a car before the horse
story it's like how do you get better if you're
not doing it but then people say just go do it
and there's plenty of stories that someone is
successful from just doing it for sure but it's a
needle in a haystack and that's going to happen a
handful of times a year with 10 000 people trying
but I mean a lot of this industry is is luck and
talent I mean I like to think that everyone has
talent everyone's talented in the industry so
if you start off at a sea of a thousand people
and every single one of them's talented and
three people are going to get caught to move on
then it's luck you know it's really luck
and networking like getting as many people
to know you exist as humanly possible is
like the real key to the whole industry
because you're literally just floundering a sea
of thousands trying to have some be like hey
I'm really talented it's like well yeah you're
really talented that guy's talented that girl's
talented everybody's talented everyone's
good especially here in Los Angeles it's
like they've made the jump they're here they're
strong they're ready to fight for what they want
so it's definitely there's definitely a lot
of different schools of thought around it
and it's trying to figure out what works best
for you and your situation is really the the
challenging one hopefully your grandparents or
the neighbor to someone really famous and they
can just make a phone call and give you a
career like that's the easy way to do it
well even with that though they still got to show
up and they still have to perform in some way
so connections I think do help I've never
had any but I have seen people who have and
it doesn't always guarantee them a job they
still have to you know and and sometimes and I
i know people are going to fight me on this when
things are too comfortable for certain people
for too long I think there's a lack of willingness
to try and that's what I was my next question was
that with certain institutions and you say they
they advocate just you know working for free or
doing different things is that a very textbook
response for people that have the money to go to
them community colleges I don't think they would
probably give that advice but maybe they would I
don't know I mean I think I would feel that and
this is across the board with all industries I
mean internships out of college or during college
is pretty consistent which is free labor it's like
you're working free labor in the industry of
your choice to gain more real world experience
and that happens everywhere that happens with
doctors it happens with I mean almost any industry
you you still go into a residency you still have
to go do the or do internships with corporations
to try to get into those positions you
want because you have to prove yourself
that you're talented and qualified
to be able to move up in the world
and that so I do agree that it's the same way in
film it's like if you're in college and you're
trying to get more experience I mean I internship
when I was in high school and summoned during
college and I got great experience and I met lots
of new people and it definitely helped me out
but it's more so the you're going to be working
for free for 10 years or the expectation that
everyone else should work for free for 10 years
that's that's where it gets frustrating because
everyone's creative and everyone wants to do
stuff and it's a lot of fun to do things and
it's awesome I mean if I could be on set every day
I would but at a point a certain point you have to
kind of decide like okay now I'm working beyond
my worth like I need to actually make money and
I need to survive and support my family and so you
have to figure out what's the best way to do that
but I think that internships is a very common
rule across the board of any any occupation
and and it's advised from any college yeah
whether whether like a prestigious four-year or
a local community college which could have just
as great of a teacher it could be the same teacher
actually yeah I mean some schools offer placement
some schools have great reputations for getting
people jobs out of college and so it all kind
of depends I mean in the writing directing world
those are the two hardest jobs to get in the
industry if you're going out to be a grip or
an electric you know you go work on the avengers
well they're hiring a hundred grips and they're
hiring two writers for that for one movie so it's
like there's lots of other opportunities you get
into a below the line position you're a production
assistant or makeup or you know yeah g e there's a
ton more work because they hire so many more of
those jobs and I have friends that just went to
those and they're like oh they they're booked for
years because they're so much opportunity there
but for someone that wants to be a little more
creative that focuses on writing and directing
or something there's way less of those jobs and
I remember in 2009 I did a short film that got
a lot of acclaim called 222. it was a graphic
horror short and we were getting calls from all
over the place new line cinema called up and I
was in florida being like oh crap like we made
a good short oh no what do we do now I remember
meeting with a management firm here and we had a
whole meeting and they were like well what do you
want to do with it and I'm like what do you mean
they're like well why'd you make the short I was
like well I wanted a calling card to show what my
abilities were to try to raise more awareness and
they're like oh you don't want to turn this into
a movie and I'm like I mean we we couldn't turn
it into a movie they're like oh you don't have
a script ready to go and I'm like no and they're
like oh all right well thanks for coming by you
know and I was like wait what what happened I
didn't get this lesson and I were talking to one
of the managers and I was like okay so you're
not you're not going to sign me but can I ask
why like I just I'm curious this is all new to me
and he was like look we represent Joel Schumacher
if this is back in 2009 we represent Joel
Schumacher we send him into meetings to try
to get directing jobs so when it's you and
Joel Schumacher Joel Schumacher in a meeting
or they have to decide between the two of you who
do you think they're going to choose and I'm like
oh well Joel Schumacher obviously and they're like
yeah that's the problem is that we can't put you
next to Joel Schumacher yet like you need to do
something big enough to be like oh this guy just
did this oh okay that's who that is and so it's
the same kind of a thing like you're constantly
proving yourself all the way up the ladder even
though I mean I've pitched a dozen major studios
in town now you know I haven't gotten any yeses
yet but I've got open door policies and I'm in
there and working the game and everything
and so it's exciting just to be part of the
system and figure out how the mechanisms work and
everything but until something happens or I get a
lucky break or something that breaks you out of
that it's it's a lot more challenging for sure
and now do you have answers ready for their
questions like the magical what do you what
else do you have oh every single project I do I
do for a very specific purpose especially shorts
if you make a short film there's usually
three reasons you make a short film one
is to do something fun with your friends two is
to take it to film festivals and try to win awards
or three use it to try to make a feature to try
to get you know to raise enough awareness and
show your capabilities at a zero budget or low
budget that we could do on a feature level so I
feel like every project should be like that
at this point that you make a project for a
very specific reason I mean every now and then
you get a for hire job like there's a new short
that I just signed on to that's just a directing
for hire and it's a company that wants us to do
this for them and I'm like sure you know you can
that can totally produce your content as well
but I think you need to have a plan because if
you do catch that lighting in a bottle you need to
know what to do with it and I was definitely I'm
really curious if I had everything prepared back
then what would have happened because now when I
make a script I do a full breakdown I do concept
art I do a poster art for every single project I'm
pitching so it's like here's this there's one that
I'm really in love with I did a full brand package
we developed a comic book and a video game app and
everything it's like look this is the whole brand
this is the marketing this is how we would do it
and then you shop it that way which is
a lot better than well I've got an idea
or I've got a script and that's it you know you
kind of at this point need to do a little bit more
leg work to be able to showcase what you can
do and some people do hypercut trailers you
know you go make a trailer with a bunch of
other footage this is the feel that we're
going for kind of a thing or or concept art or
whatnot but yeah it's I mean it's a challenge
no matter what it's all an uphill battle so
the more you're prepared for it the better.